hello I'm Imani at least 21 and I'm from
Oakland California I've been writing
screenplays since about 2013 um I wanted
to start writing screenplays because I
lived in LA for two years I moved there
from the big area because I wanted to be
actors that experience a lot of racism I
was experienced like receiving a lot of
shitty scripts like all these auditions
that I went on the scripts where I
thought were like it really terrible and
I got fed up with spending so much money
on acting classes I decided to teach
myself how to write screenplays and not
go the traditional route of going to
university because I did a lot of
research on screenwriting and screamo
degrees in film schools and one thing
that I noticed is the easiest way to
learn how to artists the
easiest way to make a film is to make a
film I've been working on this script as
ever since I started writing screenplays
I wrote this screenplay because I'm from
a place where human sex trafficking is
very prevalent I'm from a place where
lots of young people go missing a lot of
people get into the life as at such a
young age most a lot of people are
forced into the life at a very young age
and it's something that's near and dear
to my heart being a survivor of you know
prostitution and coming out I realized
that there's so much that I can do to
encourage young folks to not engage in
this lifestyle and encourage people to
steer away from me some sort of way
whether you are exploiting people or or
you are choosing to be
to the life or you are forced into it I
just want to humanize these people I
want to humanize sex workers I want to
humanize victims of sex trafficking and
prostitutes I haven't quit because I see
no reason to what else would I be doing
with my life other than writing this
film I'll probably be in in that life so
screenwriting essentially saved me from
that because before I I went to LA I was
engaging in sex work and I started at a
very young age my goal with this skirt
is to make it into a feature film I am
currently working on starting an
IndieGoGo or a Kickstarter I don't know
which funding platform I want to go with
yet but I definitely want to do a
crowdsourcing a crowdfunding campaign to
raise awareness and raise money for the
future film and I really want this film
to help launch my career because I want
to be a screenwriter I want to make more
movies and I I just really want to be a
director and a screenwriter um one
lesson screenwriting has taught me is
just because something is hard as I mean
it's impossible just because something
is hard doesn't mean you should give up
doing it I write all the time like I
fell in love with writing in the last
couple years it's so therapeutic it's so
healing and it makes me feel good to
write and to read and just to learn and
the screenwriting really changed my life
because before I started before I was
acting I was so like lost I was dancing
I was engaging in sex work and I just
wanted to focus on one thing and screen
screen writing is the thing that I've
been able to focus on
yeah one story that I do have about my
skin my career is that after I finish
writing my first screenplay my first
feature-length screenplay I send it to a
friend of mine who went to film school
who went to NYU he's a very like
talented and intelligent filmmaker and
he read my screenplay and he said either
your genius or you really took the time
to learn how to write screenplays and I
think it's a bit of both I think it's a
mixture of hope I think I am a genius
and I also think that I I I spent so
much time teaching myself how to write
screenplays when i first started i
bought like about so many books and i
watched so many YouTube videos so many
lectures on how to develop a character
on three act structure on you know the
screenwriting terms and I really fell in
love with writing screenplays and I
think that I can change the world and
i'm going to start with this screenplay
that i'm i'm i'm basically rewriting
rewriting rewriting rewriting like
rewriting that's all i'm doing at this
moment i finished the screenplay like in
august of like last year i finish the
screenplay 2015 and i'm still rewriting
and I've been through like seven edits
and I'm fine with that I feel like this
screenplay winning is made into a film
that it can't compete with you know lots
of other films I really want to go to
can like I really want to go to Cannes
Film Festival hope I'm saying that right
I really wouldn't go that would notice
in dance and I want to go to all these
film festivals it's always been my dream
to be famous I don't know blame pop
culture but it's always been my dream to
be famous and I really fell in love with
screenwriting and
yeah that's me and that's my story